hello I'm Ryan Gaul today we're talking
about the mysterious death of James
Callender
[Music]
mr. Gaul yes
so where does our story begin any
business okay no all right Richmond
Virginia
July 17th 1803 James Callender is found
floating facedown in the James River how
did he get there are you curious very
well in order to find out we need to go
back 10 years to 1793 James Callender
Scottish immigrant salacious journalists
and a drunk get a job as a stenographer
with the new Congress and he's like
guess what I don't trust any of these
assholes and I don't I don't buy what
they're doing he is suspicious to the
point where he starts digging up
information on them and so James
Reynolds shows up at a bar and says to
Alexander Hamilton hey unless you pay me
I am going to let this story out then
you were banging my wife
so Hamilton is write him a check but
more importantly he's writing the check
from the United States Treasury
so calendars like Hamilton's not only an
affair but he's taking money from our
government like how dare he do that and
he basically with
article ruined Hamilton's career
Hamilton is like god damn you God
god damn you James Callender you
son-of-a-bitch gone calendar sits back
it's like that's where I get my high but
out of the shadows comes Thomas
Jefferson it was like hey I saw what you
did with Hamilton nice work John Adams
right now is the sitting president
calendar goes hey Jefferson it's like I
want to be President
take out us out I will hook you up
calendars like I doubt you can do what I
want because I want to become the
Postmaster General of Richmond and
Jefferson goes dude I postmaster
generals of Richmond's from breakfast
calendar goes fine let's do it
bitch as let's do it
calendar writes a new article he calls
Adams Pro monarch that was bad John
Adams is sitting there going like what
no I'm not I am NOT Pro monarch but the
people believe it immediately so
Jefferson becomes president
but guess who's going to jail calendar
for sedition charges basically writing
to create revolt against the government
and calendars like this is pretty rough
but Jefferson promised me this will be
worth it and Jefferson is like holy
I'm president Adams is out I'm in and
calendar oh holy calendars in jail
hey hey Jerry Jerry
can we pardon
[Music]
can we pardon calendar and Jerry's like
nah yeah we can pardon anyone who was
your the goddamn president he goes okay
pardon calendar he gets out of jail runs
to see Jefferson
he's like tons that was awesome we did
it
let's make me the Postmaster General of
Richmond and Jefferson literally was
like yeah Jerry could you please pay
calendar $50 and then escort amount
calendars like are you kidding me
I'll take the $50 for sure but guess
what Jefferson you want to mess with me
I got one gun and that's called gossip
and compulsive gossip gossip gossip
gossip gossip gossip gossip cops
sorry that's my pillow so it doesn't
matter
and so calendar puts out a piece of
information so damning nobody could
survive it hey guess what
Jefferson's not as cool as you think uh
he is having an affair with Sally
Hemings who's Sally Hemings Oh just his
slave everyone is like what are you
kidding me what did Jerry think about
that pamphlet so Jerry is like did you
hear about this and Jefferson goes don't
put it so close to my face Jerry and
Jerry goes I can do nothing right I can
do nothing right and by the way Jerry 80
years old so everyone's like looking to
Jefferson to see what he says but guess
what he decides to ignore it he just
goes I'm sorry I don't know maybe I
don't know and he's slowly backing out
the door and calendars like no no no no
you can't leave you have to address this
everybody in my past is address these
things as they have come up and he's
just goes now and calendars jaw dropped
like what did he just pull on me and
because he didn't care the people didn't
really care as much they're like hey
calendar calendar nice try you dink his
drinking got worse he's broke
and here we are in 1803 so what happened
did he walk down to the James River and
maybe he was too wasted and he stumbled
boom hit his head floated out to the
middle and died that's possible or was
something more sinister going on he had
a lot of enemies at that point Hamilton
Adams Jefferson their founding fathers
of America and to think that they are
suspects in a murder mystery is sort of
mind-blowing I mean try to name three
bigger names the rock well I mean when
founding our nation Jack McBrayer Jack
McBrayer is actually the answer we were
looking for congratulations guys hi
murder James calendars
[Music]
you